but that time having to default defense
in that instance here's McCullum
birthday his 23rd for the playoffs yo
kids lost the ball taken away by Lillard
Lillard drives on Murray
Cooper's wave is good to your cut game
playoff yogic don't worry about making
jump shots good deed by Harris getting
the steal he takes it to the round and
slams it home it's a second series
ending shot in his career he's always
been a fearless shot maker great fake by
yogic and a beautiful touch
hey Morris misses and finally cleared by
Lilly
[Applause]
here's Aminu goes Plumlee
both teams shooting under 35% from the
floor McCallum 1/3 what pisses it home
there ever times you're watching them
where you think you just wish you'd go
post up play through the double-team and
just take over
yeah good job by cancer there
Murray saying settle down Murray rocking
the baby firing away panting another
three two triples in the last minute
from her standing how to shake loose the
handle between the legs and back
amigo goes under not in time Jamal easy
he's got 12 in 15 all of game too but
Cullum will try to answer to triple
doubles in the playoffs at 12 during the
regular season but turns it over here
numbers for Portland McCollum
[Applause]
Yogesh able to track down that task from
Murray
Jochen to sport turnovers by the way
Murray beautiful scoop and score had a
couple of defenders leave him and he got
caught in the air but somehow finish get
on the switch it's Aminu guarding Jamal
Murray Murray dribbling through traffic
to the rim and scores what a half for
Jamal Murray with 16 but when it comes
to how hard the banging has been between
yoga CH and Cantor in particular along
waiting for free throws along the foul
line we talked about that that shoulder
right at the very first possession of
the game and that is usually not a
unique collision between the two of them
that's happened three times in this game
nice pass back to Yogesh and you'll get
inside for two and one you see the
connection between Murray and yokas
games so they put them in a two-man game
on the left side of the floor it's just
the two of them right Craig is there two
offensive rebounds so much better
defensively than I expected of the big
he gave multiple efforts on that play
this is where you knew it helped you
[Applause]
the old-fashioned way for cancer yogic
spinning and finishing so beautifully
done on the low block by the Joker 4th
year you've got to be close enough to
could test
[Applause]
they were trapping Lillard in that
series against New Orleans at that space
now it goes to cancer and finds Morris
on the wings
yo gets with one to shoot floats it up
and in what did we tell you though right
this guy averages 30 more touches
absolutely dynamic all year they get
that defender committed put it on the
deck big fella how about the touch role
in yogic offensive rebound Collins pulls
it back it's amazing he could say play
our game that gave him defense how about
that perchance Oh finished by yo kids
going under the hoop and getting it to
go watch how quickly the spin comes he
just he senses it that's just a fuse
been quiet since a couple of quick
buckets to start the third quarter still
has 20 points for the game McCollum gets
past
[Music]
those were for Keith shootings McCallum
[Applause]
has probably always been a bit
undersized so getting separation using
your handle using your touch he is
moving away from the rim that is not
easy yogic fries and a choker says way
to they get a load of me McCallum drives
on Harris stripped and lost the ball
numbers for Denver if they hurry marry
all the way lawns by Lillard but Mary
finishes to tie the game at 93 the strip
and then two-on-one and watch Damian
never commits so Murray makes the exact
right Reaper use got 22 points he draws
cancer now and the shot pocket three
step back Murray over cancer good it's a
two pointer and a two point lead and
this guy is young Murray gets cancer
again the shot clock at two
Mary drains it and the lead is five for
Denver
Jean Harris takes it kicks it out
heartless in the paint
[Applause]
Lillard splits defenders corner
reciprocal his first point to the floor
you gotta have some mental toughness
Jamal Murray has a shot Torrey Craig has
a shot
Lillard the fearless shot shot clock is
off limit takes it himself and blue the
way up to Aminu here's McCollum driving
the clock you end up with a turnover
Lillard misses a little finger roll
great job by Aminu to keep control and
CJ delivers yet again all seven folks
dragon on the floor right now
Lillard steps back his two switches at
home they've got the Blazers a two-point
wave or the end of the fourth quarter
had a two possession lead where the
Blazers get one here they work at around
the Lillard Bob's away from
seeing whether he could make the NBA but
driven confident fearless delivery
and look at him just stay spaced
Amino the extra pass and Dave will work
to sing whether he can make the NBA but
driven confident fearless delivery just
that little bit of an exchange by Murray
and Millsap and it leads to indecision
and bucket but column five Barton trying
to save it
good night starting lineup and they
started to win he could have complained
he could have become a problem he's kept
playing and guess who's closing the game
da clock down to six McCallum comes and
gets it with a timer at four Barton on
him McCullum drives two on the shot
clock
poaching a minute to go Denver trailing
by two they've been so resilient all my
Harris pins with the left he finishes
off the window were even at 118
happening but that's a sloppy pass the
column step back over Barton hits go
again
burries finds Millsap timer at four
Millsaps spins it's over heartless Wow
just this took a long time for Murray to
get the ball right here but how about
that shot by Paul Millsap McComas played
55 minutes
Lillard played 52 he gets by Craig takes
it to the rim and gets the layup
so they score within four seconds to
make it a two-point game there's a
three-second difference between the game
and shot clock
Horry charge was shutting down Lillard
here in the clutch now the switch Craig
gets him back
here's Lillard driving Denver players
he's sitting there going I'm gonna be
close enough to contest and Craig gets
beat looks like he might get a piece
from behind but you're playing them
straight up and that's all you need
right Dave decides when that race begins
after the hesitation Wright's not always
who's the fastest who's deciding when
that thing starts and once he hesitated
now he determines hesitate and go and if
you're Craig you got a respect right the
step back three Denver players he's
sitting there going I'm gonna be close
enough to contest and Craig gets beat
looks like he might get a piece from
behind that's a play call I think from
the sidelines and boy just with a
light-duty 9 finish it Millsap with a
sweet defensive rotation to get the
block but Hart was playing 42 minutes we
weren't even sure he was going to play
tonight because of his injury Barton so
good in the second half and overtime
he's got 19 since intermission look
backing down
Marie's she's got the freshest legs of
anybody on the floor takes the shot when
they have had an opportunity they have
hunted Jamal Murray on the post up we've
seen it with heartless and in this
instance we see it with Rodney hood and
I said to Mike Malone before the game I
said with the way the Spurs attack
Murray and with the way now Portland is
attacking me and I said to Mike Malone
before the game I said with the way the
Spurs attack Murray and with the way now
Portland is attacking shot clock at 8
Millsap goes to the left hand
what a shot by Millsap to get Denver a
one-point lead post get it to your most
experienced guy why is it important to
be able to finish with Bolton hands
because post get it to your most
experienced guy why is it important to
be able to finish with both hands
because he had no shot of getting that
off with the right back and down a
Meanor who's got great legs could have
been an n1 I mean that's it that's a
push with the right arm
I actually liked them for calling
driving over to Nuggets off the heels
got it back to hood he'll try a free
blazars by 2pi
the only guy that's not exhausted the
win on the road CJ over two defenders
offensive rebounds his own miss how
about the up fake and poised to stay in
three by mr. hood who also had three
blocks the last game look at him this
isn't somebody who's dunking in the
corner this is I'm out here at three Oh
Roland fly by the defender you don't
show discipline I put it down the
acquisitions by Niall O'Shea and Terry
Stotts at three blocks the last game
look at him
this isn't somebody who's dunking in the
corner this is I'm out here at three
unrolling slide five a defender you
don't show discipline I put it down the
acquisitions by Niall O'Shea and Terry
Stotts